so I want to think again I want to give
you a another analogy for thinking about
how these things relate okay
now I'll just give you a warning okay
you might not like this analogy because
it's sort of related to physics okay and
I know not everyone likes physics okay
but number one number one I think it's a
helpful analogy number two
you will have to deal with this idea
next year when you do the topic called
emotion okay so if you would like to not
do that even to unisons to emotion so
you will have to drop maths if you
really dislike this idea that much okay
so here we go do you remember the other
day I took the Apple right and I tossed
it up and down and up and down and then
I drew it right I sketched it okay so in
that case our vertical axis which were
usually called Y corresponding to
location okay or if you like if you want
to use a more specific word it
correspond to displacement right how far
was I displaced from my original
starting point which to my head okay
yeah well at the start it was but then
when I tossed it up you know it wasn't
exactly okay now that's that's location
of displacement now when I differentiate
it what did I get okay well this
derivative is how this is changing over
you know the horizontal axis which we
named time okay so really how is
displacement changing how is location
changing we have a name for that it's
called speed right because when we say
30 km/h what that means is how is your
displacement changing over a given time
period okay but instead of our
horizontal axis being time usually our
horizontal axis is X okay so how is y
changing as X changes if you want it to
be
again we more specific you would say
velocity okay because actually Direction
matters and speed it's just not about it
okay now therefore can be feeling the
energy okay if this is how this is
changing velocity is how displacement is
changing what what name do we give to
the rate at which velocity is
and the answer is acceleration right so
what this corresponds to is okay how is
your speed changing over time so as you
put your pedal on the foot okay your
speed isn't just staying at 30 K by the
acceleration yeah this is where the
analogy breaks down okay
because I would say if I've got my foot
on the pedal that's acceleration but if
I put my through a break normally we
would not say that's acceleration right
because yeah you're getting slower right
but actually it is acceleration in the
sense that what velocity is changing
it's just that it's slowing down right
so that's like the first part of math
okay that's on there okay sir I'm still
increasing but I'm slowing down the
brakes are on so I'm accelerating it
just happens to be in that direction
okay which by the way is what I've
gravity was doing when I toss the Apple
up and down okay
it was um if you like again this is the
physics language Dawson this is the
language of forces okay you've got
something that's pushing in another
direction okay and changing the velocity
okay